we're asked to solve the proportion 8
over 36 is equal to 10 over n so we need
to figure out we need to figure out what
n is and the easiest way to do this is
to multiply both sides of this equation
by both denominators so if we multiply
both sides of this equation by n if we
multiply both sides by n what do we get
so let's multiply it first by n so if
you multiply both sides first by n and
the whole purpose of doing that is so
that this end in the denominator will
cancel out with this end which is
essentially in the numerator you could
view this as n over 1 so if you do that
the left hand side of our equation
becomes 8 over 36 times n or you can
even view it as 8 and over 36 because
you could really view this as an N over
1 and n over 1 so the left hand side
becomes 8 n over 36 and then that will
be equal to 10 over N times n over 1
this end and that end canceled out and
left with 10 over 1 or just 10 now we
can multiply both sides of this equation
to really get rid of that 36 in the
denominator we can multiply both sides
by 36 or you can imagine by 36 over 1
either way 36 over the 1 is the same
thing as 36 this 36 cancels out with
that 36 and the left hand side we have
8n and on the right hand side is equal
to 10 times 36 is 360 now to solve for n
we can just divide both sides of this
equation by 8 so if you divide that side
by 8 and that side by 8 the left hand
side the eights will cancel out and you
are left with n is equal to 360 divided
by 8 and we can figure out what that
actually is 8 goes into 360 so 8 is the
visible not into 3 it's divisible 2 36 4
times 4 times 8 is 32 subtract 6 minus 2
is 4 3 minus 3 is nothing bring down the
0 8 goes into 40 exactly 5 times 5 times
a
is 40 and then you have no remainder so
n is equal to 360 over 8 which is the
exact same thing which is the exact same
thing as 45 so going back to our
original proportion we now solve for N
and we know we know that 8 over 36 is
the same exact thing is the same exact
thing as 10 over 45